l'opievoy l'office hlm n'a plus de
direction le 22 novembre dernier michel
vialay mise en minorité sur le vote de
la nomination d'un nouveau directeur
général
résultat le président de l'ot pivois
démissionne accompagné des représentants
des conseils généraux des yvelines et du
val d'oise
cette démission collective bloc alors le
vote du budget annuel et paralyse le
fonctionnement de l'office
ça a bloqué la réputation de la grande
borne ça a bloqué la réhabilitation du
valais ou un plaisir ça a bloqué des
projets d'innovation sociale avec des
associations
donc ça bloquait toute la machine
opievoy et derrière ça ça aussi
énormément inquiéter 1000 salariés
michel vialay justifie son départ par le
flou de la trésorerie
selon lui plusieurs dizaines de millions
d'euros de fonds propres a disparu rien
sans le maire de mont-joli entend
dénoncer l'absence de transparence dans
la gestion budgétaire du deuxième
offices publics de l'habitat français
qu'il s'agisse de la gestion financière
qu'il s'agisse de la gestion budgétaire
de la stratégie patrimoniale de tout ce
qui engage le fils dans la durée un
grand nombre d'informations ne sont pas
ni satisfaisante ni complète
qu'il s'agisse de l'endettement qui lui
a crû dans des proportions extrêmement
rapide en l'espace de tout juste 3 ans
de leur côté les administrateurs déplore
un manque de dialogue criant avec leur
président démissionnaire ils ont saisi
le préfet des yvelines
ce dernier a conseillé la tenue d'une
nouvelle réunion d'ici une semaine
l'opievoy gère 50 mille logements en ile
de france dont plus de 18000 dans le
département